ok google stoppt sein konkret die bahn
[Gelächter]
lieber in cocktails was ist ein glühwein
kopf es gibt immer eine hauptzutat und
heute ist die hauptzutat okay ist nicht
frei
ja ich gehe einkaufen bis gleich ruhig
[Musik]
mit dem fertigen für den glühwein hier
ich nicht hey leute was hast du da
eigentlich weißen glühwein ich habe mein
leben noch nie weißt wie beim getrunken
aber ich mache meine heute selber wenn
über na ja ich habe keine lust mich noch
mal ich habe viele gewürze
ich habe so extreme kommt also nur der
hatte passt zu wild herzhaftem
fleischgerichten und würzigen käse man
vielleicht sagen du bist würziger käse
herzlich und ich bin bild will total
du wirst du willst gebäude nicht kennen
ich bin aus der rolle wir müssen viel zu
kalten vorstellen einfach so ich fange
abend links first mit glühwein orangen
dann habe ich noch rum kater dass davon
kriegst du eine karte so spart ihr habt
da steht nämlich kam medienrummel der
queen
ich mache eine kleine reise und zwar ist
das ja so weihnachtlich im winter und
weil es im winter kalt ist und
unangenehm ist dass wir uns zurück in
den sommer wünschen und damals so eine
fusion aus das krass also ich habe
weißen glühwein
das war wir haben dazu nehmen zwei und
die sich mit ford gab die genivi harz
und angeblich sogar gesetzt
eingreifkräfte ananassaft und zu jener
bären saft aus dem wir haben sagt
konzentrat oder solange dein kippen bis
erträglich ist und irgendwie gut
aussieht solange ein kippen
verträglich ist und irgendwie gut
aussieht und das kommt für mich auch
noch rein
also ich würde ganz krasse fehler ihr
werdet bei mir lernen wie ihr glühwein
machthaber die weiter kompakt
ich habe meinen solche beigaben habe
sternanis und ich habe im moment dazu
habe ich genau diese von den früchten
vorbereitet du und ich habe sie zuerst
mal die praktisch gesehen
mit dem rabatt halle bär sagt man
erwarte ja erwarte ich hab gleich kippen
dachte ich hier gibt's auch das ist ja
kann man mit schutz genauso wie man mit
schuss quasi bestimmt die kann man ja
wir schließen er hasst du hast du für
den film war ganz okay gut ich musste
erst mal nicht vortäuschen informatik
ist das nicht gut ist es möglich machen
also ich wollte bekommt den ball problem
das ist allemal besser das was ich hier
mache ist übrigens über geyer wir müssen
dafür nicht verkleinern ich mache das
nur damit es schneller geht
[Musik]
er muss auch schön rein da kann man sich
nur hasen können nicht noch ein bisschen
billig wirken dann zugriff möglich
[Musik]
ich wäre auch so ein scheiß wieso und so
was er tun soll das wieder voll drin
er hatte als man denken warum die stadt
steht ein anderes plätzchen okay leute
bringt mich auch sehr gut bei mir
schneller fertig sind als du denn heute
auch bonuspunkte oder ja es ist schon
die produkte ja wie schnell hier
wenn du zum beispiel fleisch allen
gleich zurück droht dort schon sehr bald
auf guten morgen internet will jan delay
bekomme ich ihn so etwas gerade was
einschätzen
hier dass man es nicht übertreiben
sollte ja genau deswegen glaube ich hab
den fingern und wo seid ihr eigentlich
alle
ich glaube ich muss wissen wenn in
seinem auftrag verbrauchen ja weil ich
würde auf ein paar worte übrig bleiben
aber kein abbott kinder gericht
[Musik]
so was zum naschen ich ohne scheibe für
sich wirklich kenne hier stehen würde
hat sie ihren parteifreund ja das ist
richtig geil dass ich mit meinen fühlst
du vielleicht noch mal überdenken
müssten sofort hier ich habe erfolgen
rum
ich glaube ich noch ein bisschen rum
jetzt verstehe ich das prinzip in einem
cocktail du hast einen vitaminreichen
korb der mitten im 2 vitamine und
maschen genau weiß ich das gewohnt und
kindergerecht alles sich hier um ein
außerordentlich wichtiges produkt für
die eltern handelt wiederholt nimm2
diese werbeeinschaltung lebten nach
meinen sie im 2 also muss einfach
verkaufen zu sagen
die gleiche scheiß machen mich denn
milch mit dem das würde ich nicht hier
manchmal schaue ich hab ihm entfernt ist
ja der chip wird nur mehr alkohol oder
damit ich kenne in die fussstapfen
treten muss funktionieren oder kelly in
die physiker hat allerdings zwei seiten
weil das ist also mal zwischendurch
die sache
gibt's da nicht etwas auf euren kanal zu
dieser kombination süßigkeiten liköre
tatsächlich ist mit zwei von fünf bands
und sehe dass jemand wenn ich also falls
ihr euch dafür interessieren sollte wie
man sie sich keinen regel bereit ist das
projekt schon gern bei uns vorbei 26 ps
radio danke wir machen schon mal werbung
geht es uns upgrades ab weil es sich
hier um ein außerordentlich wichtiges
produkt für die eltern handelt
wiederholt neben zwei diese
werbeeinschaltung alkohol kann es
mittlerweile als noch damals also
praktikum bei uns ja ich hab mal wach
wenn ich aber den bergstrecken gemacht
ja als ich auf die gleiche schule
gegangen dafür gefeuert ich lasse den
rathaus ein bisschen zusammen kommen
aber wenn du ja gut ich weiß nicht ob
meiner sobald es nicht allzu viel
ich habe gar nicht probiert also ich
dass mich überrascht nichts ich bin hier
ja also ich hab ich habe den punkt
bringen ich bin tatsächlich der einzige
bei dir so einen richtigen glykol
übergekocht derweil das einzige was er
bekommt dann sind nämlich nicht haben
so bieten wir deshalb angst mit meiner
wird kalt ich denn da machen wir dann
zuerst wenn man egal welchen kurz
vorstellen
sie sehen hier ein selbstgemacht global
mit granatapfel boden auf heidelbeer um
basis mit zeug dran
[Musik]
schmeckt nach glühwein schmeckt auf
jeden fall nach drüber nach über 18 ja
aber ich hab' ich werde gut gekocht und
so erstickt so ist ein bisschen oder ist
okay machen über damit ein oder ich habe
einen milchshake jetzt ein bisschen das
ist pistazie uhr an fassade und
kokosflocken sind obendrauf mit sahne
und hier ist glühwein und hungrig ist
und kokos einen mäßig young ich gesagt
ja es ist glaube ich fast nicht wie ich
hab ich kein bock dass der typ gewinnen
und das haben wir hier wir haben wir
weißen glühwein auf dem mixed mit nimmt
zwei wort gab das heißt nicht zweimal
wodka und ein bonbon wodka erträglich
gemacht mit verschiedensten mitteln
schuss limette jemanden hier sogar sieht
man äpfel
ich dachte dass ich beschloss im grund
warum die 280 haben und eine
entschuldigung hast spiegelt unser
unserer situation immer wieder zweifel
eine liebe ja toll wir sind die karoli
einfach nach
ist es jetzt dass ich scheiße oder park
ich habe gewonnen
[Musik]
weiß
was hat unser genannten ein bonbon wodka
mit einem schuss schrot und limette die
muss zu verhelfen
ja es ist ein job
ich möchte den 2 es ist so eine
verbindung zur kindheit und ein chor ist
nicht meine welt
nimm2 also uni mainz es ist eben gerecht
das hat sogar mit aluminium wenn ihr
euren job bringt etwas schönes städtchen
auch wieder zu ersten damit eure mit dem
haus ist schon starken der muss auch in
deutschland sein der muss kann seine
eier
wenn ihr wissen wollt werden die beiden
sind dann fragt google ja ok google wer
sind diese zwei aus dem internet eine
brille
der andere nicht und sie machen lustige
videos ich auch nicht haben auch unseren
content noch nicht verstanden ja das
passt eigentlich nicht dass wir hier
sein dürfen also erst mal sehr schön ich
trinke immer sehr jahre mit dir nochmal
fragt in den kommentaren hat sich
nochmal gekommen sein
warum nicht mal bis ins jahr wurde
absolut habe also überraschungssiegern
hier
wir freuen uns gekauft alles lief gut
ich wusste er bereits dass mit den
bonbons funktioniert obwohl jetzt gar
nicht so viel dazu beitragen machen wir
den wodka lustig